[Music]
from the dumb car racing franchise that
just won't run out of gas comes the
third film that was one Vin Diesel cameo
away from totaling the whole thing
The Fast and the Furious
Tokyo Drift returned to the dark pre
rock era of fast and furious before
Universal new people actually wanted to
watch these things and try to get pumped
for a fast film without any of the main
characters no connection to the first
two and at needlessly complicated
timeline but it does have the most
actual street racing watching people
lean to the side is fun right you see
the cars and butts of Los Angeles you've
seen the cars and butts of Miami now
travel across the globe for the cars and
butts of Tokyo a city in the middle of a
big retro tech phase because this takes
place after fast 6 and they still have
flip phones iPods and Lil Bow Wow
and they have a laptop enter the
underground world of drifting a skid
based racing style with an origin that
sounds like totally bullsh for stress
there's advantage drifting out here in
the mountains but turns out to be more
or less true
whoa next thing you're gonna tell me
NASCAR was invented by rum-running
bootleggers what next thing you're gonna
tell me is the submarine chaser and fast
eight is based on real life - no you're
not gonna tell me that well it should be
i watch the hell of that meet an all-new
family you won't be spending too much
time with like ha the snack man
DK the gangster with an uncle complex
doesn't his henchman with the weird
laugh various girl shaped objects winner
gets me and a little bow well that goes
a long way
strap in as they all take a backseat to
Shawn a 24 year old that looks like a 34
year old playing a 17 year old is
underage
who against all odds is the worst actor
in a franchise with Vin Diesel in it
Mourad thrill as this good old boy
street racer struggles to overcome the
same weakness as Derek Zoolander can
turn left
[Applause]
I'm not an ammeter
and struggles to deliver lines that
don't sound like a badly programmed
southern robot I did this I can't run
away
I can't so if you don't drift the win
what do you drift fool no need to tell
us you're not a trained actor on your
IMDB page man we could tell normally now
where you live
where'd you come from so scrap it as
director justin lin attempts the
impossible create a semi passable sequel
to Point Break with cars and Brokeback
Mountain with cars without any of the
actors or storylines that made them
popular that managed to make audiences
everywhere say man I actually missed the
subtle nuance of Paul Walker and Tyrese
good job
starring florid gum Yakuza
hanging with Mini Cooper and row tied
car wars episode 3 Revenge of the shift
come up to sunny with us someone oh god
he mas
when did he learn how to speak Japanese
he can barely speak Alabaman hey screen
junkies want to hit the nos on more fast
and furious then click the boxes above
to check out our previous honest
trailers for the fast franchise Java
Dana - I love my nachos you can't have
them pineapple pickle pancakes
prostrating profusely to the PO three
times fast
I have rug nuggets in my ham I want a
wedgie and I want it now
yes Queens leg ass